life is returning to some kind of normal
in Dortmund cafes and restaurants are
back open drinks with friends once more
but perhaps the most radical move of
lockdown lifting so far is the return of
professional football fans won't be
allowed if they do gather outside
stadiums matches will be abandoned here
they call them ghost games but the world
is watching the westfalen studyin will
host one of the biggest games in German
football the derby between Dortmund and
their bitter local rival Schalke has
been played 179 times before but never
like this the players have been staying
in quarantine hotels regularly tested
for kovat 19 those in charge know that
if this plan is successful it could be
used as a blueprint around the world
including for the Premier League we also
got calls or mails from from big clubs
from Spain and England and I know that
they you know that they really hope that
we will manage this situation so that
other leaks can have a restart as well
Germany's players agreed to return to
training last month most will experience
for the first time playing in empty
stadiums but this app could offer a
solution some clubs including Premier
League teams they're considering
allowing fans to pub noise inside
stadiums with a click of a button
placement for fans there's no
replacement for stadiums we really want
things to get back to normal but
probably to take months and until that
happens and we want people to have fun
with any alternative while this is still
lasting in England the future is less
certain players remain unsure about
whether it's too soon for the
professional game to return Adam Clayton
understands the devastating effects of
coronavirus
this is his dad's feed leaving ICU after
51 days this week it's just got to be
safe I think I've seen sort of I have
seen the damage sort of firsthand it can
do to sort of families and a family
member in particular and to see all that
sort of stuff I'd be or be hesitant to
want anybody else to be putting that in
in that situation in that scenario the
next stage of the experiment is underway
the situation is different in Germany
but if this weekend goes well it will
give confidence that English football
too may be back on again Martha Kellner
Sky News Dortmund